the new prime minister here just two
weeks ago promising to restore Integrity
to Downing Street now heading to the
commons to explain why he put Gavin
Williamson in cabinet only to lose him
in record time amid accusations of
bullying
Rishi sunak's third ever prime
minister's questions this one was never
going to be easy the resignation a gift
for the labor leader everyone in the
country also knows someone like the
Prime Minister the boss who is so weak
so worried the bullies will turn on him
that he hides behind them
seemingly deep in thought he needed a
prompt from colleagues to respond
Mr Speaker the message that I clearly
want to send is that Integrity in public
life matters
[Applause]
as resign sitting next to him the other
cabinet minister facing calls to resign
Home Secretary swella bravaman always
forging her own path speaking to the
police but with an appeal that would go
down well with the Tory party faithful
what I call Common Sense policing the
kind of policing that the law-abiding
patriotic majority of British people
deserves and expects
no politically correct distractions just
good old-fashioned policing another
cabinet minister getting noticed just as
Rishi sunak is trying to calm tensions
labor believed that they can convince
voters that the man in there is weak at
the mercy of events and factions and big
personalities and for all of his many
faults gather Williamson was one
individual who could guide Rishi sunac
through difficult Waters starting next
week when the new prime minister has to
decide how much to put up taxes next
Thursday's Autumn statement a defining
moment for Rishi sunak but already there
are warnings from his own side well
it'll be deep concern if we go over the
top on tax Rises because as I say it's
absolutely a fact of life the tax risers
will make the recession deeper is Rishi
sunak Tough Enough To Face Down all of
these challenges
welcome to Politics as it is there is
never an easy good time in politics
Rishi sunak surrounded by the trappings
of the Office of Prime Minister but that
only gets you so far steady his eyes
they tell their own story Sam coats Sky
News